ADAM MARTIN: And so I just
want to say a couple sentences
about DNA sequencing,
just to finish that up.
And so you'll remember this
slide from last lecture.
And remember, the way this
Sanger technique works
is to set up four
different reactions where
each reaction has
a different one
of these dideoxynucleotides.
OK, so there's four
reactions, each
with different dideoxy NTP.
And I brought along a gel
that I ran a while ago,
which is basically-- it's from
sequencing gel, and you can--
I'll pass this around so
you can take a look at it.
So the four different
lanes for each sample
are the different
dideoxynucleotide reactions.
And what I want you to notice
as that's passing around
and you're looking at it is
that the different reactions
with the different
dideoxynucleotides
give different patterns
of DNA fragment lengths.
So there are different
patterns of fragment lengths.
And the different patterns
are based on the fact--
this is based on the sequence,
the sequence of the template,
OK?
And so if we look at the
example up here, what you'll see
is that in this banding
pattern for dideoxy TTP,
you see that there's a really
short fragment at the bottom
there, and so that fragment
indicates that there must be
an A in the template sequence.
The next fragment up would be
this one in the dideoxy GTP
lane, and that indicates that
one nucleotide beyond this A
is a C position, and
so on and so forth,
such that you can sort
of order the fragments
and see which reaction
has a fragment
and then read off
a DNA sequence.
OK, so conceptually,
that's how you
would read off the sequence
of a given strand of DNA, OK?
So you might be wondering,
if now, we just read off
sequence as a series of colors,
why am I even introducing
this technique?
And the reason is
because I think
it's important for you as
potentially future scientists
to know that when you're
faced with a problem,
how you might discover
something new.
And I see the
Sanger method of DNA
sequencing as a really
clever and elegant way
in which Fred Sanger solved
the problem of DNA sequencing,
and while we don't necessarily
do it that way today, it still
illustrates a concept
that's important,
the concept of
chain termination,
and I think there is something
to be learned from this older
technique, even if
it's not exactly how we
sequence DNA today.
So for today's
lecture, we're going
to continue on our quest to
basically clone a gene that's
responsible for a disease.
And so we started this
in the last lecture.
And I guess one
thing we would want
to start with is
a disease, so I'm
going to introduce to you now
a disease called aniridia.
And in order to clone
the gene for a disease,
it has to be a
heritable disease,
in this case, because we're
going to use linkage analysis
to identify it.
So aniridia is a disease that's
an eye disease in humans.
It's a rare eye disease.
So I want to show you a bit of
an example of this eye disease.
The way this disease
manifests itself
is it's basically the
affected individual
has an eye that is
lacking an iris.
So I'm going to show you
what this looks like.
If you're squeamish or
don't like weird eyes
and you don't want to
look, you can look away.
But I will show you affected
phenotype in 3, 2, 1, OK,
everyone looking who
wants to see weird eyes.
OK, good.
So that is a individual that
has aniridia, and also this one.
So you see there's no
clear iris in these eyes.
And this disease is associated
with other abnormalities
of the eye that
severely impair vision.
And this is an
inherited disease,
and this is a
pedigree from a family
or series of families where
the disease is propagating.
And so anyone have a suggestion
as to what mode of inheritance
this is?
Anyone want to rule a mode out?
Rachel, you have an idea?
AUDIENCE: I was going to
say X-linked dominant,
but [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: OK, so let's
take X-linked dominant.
So if it was X-linked
dominant, then this male
would have an X chromosome
with the dominant allele
of the disease and should
only pass it to his females.
So I don't think that
it would necessarily
be X-linked dominant.
Anyone else have an idea?
Yeah, Georgia?
AUDIENCE: Autosomal.
ADAM MARTIN: Autosomal dominant.
I like autosomal dominant.
So in this case,
you see you have
an individual with
the disease and they
marry into a family with
no history of the disease.
One thing I'll point out,
for many of these diseases,
they're extremely rare, so if
you see sort of a family tree
where there's no
instance of the disease,
if it's a rare
disease, it's likely
that these individuals
are not carriers.
And so in this case, if you
assume that this person doesn't
have any form of the--
isn't a carrier for
the disease, then this
cross here resulting
in about half
of the individuals affected
with the disease, that
would be a characteristic of
an autosomal dominant disease.
So everyone understand my logic?
Yes, Carlos?
AUDIENCE: What are--
why is two and that
looks like three on the slide,
why are they crossed out?
ADAM MARTIN: I think
they're deceased.
Yes.
OK, so let's say
you have a pedigree.
You have pedigrees, you're able
to try to link this marker to--
or the disease phenotype with
various molecular markers,
which we discussed in
last week's lectures,
then you're on the
way to performing
a process which is known
as positional gene cloning.
And what positional
gene cloning is
is it's basically cloning
a gene and a allele that's
responsible for a disease based
on its position in the genome,
it's position in a particular
chromosomal region.
So it's basically
cloning a gene based
on its chromosomal position
or its chromosome position.
And the first step of
positional gene cloning
would be to establish maybe
what chromosome it's on.
And a straightforward way to
do this, as we've basically
been discussing almost from
when I started lecturing,
is to create some
sort of linkage
map or do linkage
mapping to identify,
in the case of humans, molecular
markers that this disease
allele is linked to.
And remember, in
last week's lecture,
we talked about a number
of different polymorphisms
that are present
in the human genome
that we can use to establish
linkage with a given phenotype.
In this case, it's
a human disease.
And we talked about this example
for a microsatellite marker.
And in this case, we
talked through this example
of how this dominant
allele, P, is linked
to this microsatellite
allele m double prime,
because if you look
at the pedigree here,
all of the affected
individuals here
contain this m double
prime sized fragment
for this microsatellite.
Another thing to
notice here is you
can see that this couple has
been faithful to each other,
because basically,
each of the children
have an allele from the father
and an allele from the mother.
So you can see that type of--
you can see that using this type
of molecular marker as well.
OK, so you establish linkage.
So linkage mapping establishes
the chromosome position
of a given allele and the gene.
And this chromosome
position sort of
gets maybe in the right
country, but you still
have a long way before you get
to the specific street address.
And so you have to then
sort of narrow it in
to identify a smaller region
of the chromosome that could
possibly contain this gene.
And so what you would do is go
from this linkage map, where
you maybe identify the position
of this gene within a couple
map units, to this
next resolution of map
called a physical map, OK?
So we go from the
linkage position
to the physical map
of the chromosome.
And the physical map,
as the name implies,
is when you have
physical pieces of DNA
that are present in this
region of the chromosome.
So the physical
map means you have
cloned, so recombinant
pieces of DNA,
cloned pieces of DNA which
encompass a given chromosome
region.
So these are encompassing
a chromosome region.
OK, so how would you
get a piece of DNA
that sort of is in this region?
How would you start?
How would you start
fishing for that DNA?
So you've gone through
the process of linkage,
you've identified sort
of a polymorphism that is
linked to the disease allele.
How would you go from there to
getting a physical piece of DNA
that is present in that
region of the chromosome?
So let's think back to--
Jeremy, did you have an idea?
AUDIENCE: Start by using PCR
to just amplify that chunk.
[INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: And what
primers, I guess,
would you use for the PCR?
AUDIENCE: Depending on which
chunk you're trying to get,
you'd use [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: OK,
so Jeremy is saying
if you knew the
sequence, and I guess
if you're doing this
microsatellite analysis,
you had primers that recognize
a sequence at a given
genomic position, so you
actually know something
about the sequence because
of this polymorphism,
so you can use that knowledge
to then look for this sequence.
And you could even look for
the microsatellite in a DNA
library.
OK, so you have
cloned pieces of DNA,
and you're going to start with--
I'm going to swap this.
Your starting
position could be one
of these polymorphisms in
the sequence around it,
which you already know.
So let's say you had this
microsatellite marker.
You could then--
what I'm drawing here
is a piece of genomic DNA.
So this is genomic DNA.
I'm just drawing the insert.
This would be recombinant DNA.
It would be present in
some vector or plasmid.
But if you can identify
the sequence that
contains this
microsatellite marker,
then you would have the
microsatellite, but also
the surrounding DNA, OK?
So that sort of anchors
you at a given position.
Now, you don't know if your
gene is in that piece of DNA,
but you know that
it's linked, and so it
should be around that
piece of DNA somewhere.
And so it's unlikely
your gene is
going to be on this small
piece of DNA that's cloned.
This is probably just a
few kb, and you could still
be very far away
from this, but that
serves as a starting point
from which you can go from
to get more and
more pieces of DNA
such that eventually, you
have a bunch of pieces of DNA
that are going to span
the entire region.
So the way you identify
other pieces of DNA is you
could start with a piece of DNA
maybe at the end of this insert
and look for other
inserts that are not
identical to this piece that
also contain this piece here.
So that might get
you a piece that's
overlapping, but extends
farther than your initial piece.
So now you've moved
slightly farther away
from your starting point, which
is this starting polymorphism.
Then you could choose maybe
another DNA sequence here
and look for a piece
of DNA that, again,
is extending a bit farther out.
And so you can see
how iteratively,
you can get farther and farther
away from this starting point
that you know your
gene is linked to.
And this process of going
sort piece by piece and clone
by clone away from
a starting position
is known as a chromosome walk.
And you can do this
bidirectionally.
So you could also start
with a sequence of DNA
here and look for a clone
that goes the other way.
And you can see on
my slide up there,
you can see that in
this case, they've
taken a one map unit
region of the chromosome
and they're illustrating
physical pieces of DNA that
are overlapping that
encompass this entire region.
So this could be much bigger
than the amount of DNA that
would fit in one of these
clones in the bacteria,
but by sort of identify
overlapping clones,
you get the entire region.
And what this is called here,
because these pieces of DNA
are contiguous with each other,
this is known as a contig.
Yeah, Jeremy?
AUDIENCE: So would
how you get the--
once you find one
of those pieces,
how do you get the primer
for the end of it to start?
Do you actually sequence
each of these pieces of DNA?
ADAM MARTIN: You
could sequence it,
or you could use a
technique that I'm
going to talk about at the
end of my lecture, which
I'll come back to.
So nowadays, you'd probably just
sequence it and then maybe look
for that in another clone.
But even before we could
sequence DNA in entire genomes,
you could do that
type of experiment
by using a technique
called hybridization,
which I'll come back to.
OK, so the question in this
chromosome walk then becomes,
how do you know when to stop?
Because you could do this
for a very long time,
but it might not be useful.
So you have to
know when to stop,
and you need to know when
you arrive at the gene
that you're interested in,
which would be the gene that
is responsible for the disease.
So another way to
phrase this question is,
how do you know when you have
an interesting gene on one
of these fragments?
So let's say this is an
interesting gene here.
How do you identify
interesting genes?
So now, let's talk about
identifying interesting genes.
Anyone have an idea
for how they would--
what criteria they would use
to define a gene as being
interesting here?
I mean, one could say that
all genes are interesting.
If it's a gene, it's
interesting, right?
How might we define whether or
not there's a gene even there?
It could be-- there
could be a gene--
how would you define a gene?
Can someone define
for me a gene?
Yeah, Miles?
Is it Miles?
No?
Malik, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] that would
create a starting and stopping
point.
So like [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: So you'd look
for a piece of DNA that
has a start and a stop codon?
So you'd look for an open
reading frame, basically.
Yeah.
You could look for an
open reading frame.
And so I totally agree
with Malik there.
And another criteria
you could use
is if it's encoding a
protein, at some point,
it also must have been
transcribed as an mRNA.
And there are some genes
that are transcribed as RNA
but don't make a protein,
and they're often
involved in coding or in
regulation of gene expression.
So I'm going to--
I'm going to say,
is it transcribed?
So is there some
transcript that's made?
And specifically, is it
transcribed in the tissue
that we're interested in?
So if we're talking
aniridia, we might
be looking for genes that are
being expressed or transcribed
specifically in eyes.
You're looking
for something that
might be expressed in the eye.
If it's not
expressed in the eye,
that gene's going to be
much less interesting to you
because the phenotype of
aniridia is clearly in the eye.
OK, what might be some
other criteria here?
Well, one criteria might be,
is there a conserved gene that
has an interesting
function that's
maybe similar to the
disease related phenotype?
So is there a conserved gene
with an interesting function?
And to take this
example of aniridia,
let's say you're doing
this chromosome walk,
and you identify
a gene, maybe you
sequence part of this clone,
you get a string of sequence,
and you realize that the
sequence that you get
is related to a gene
from a model organism,
and maybe that gene
is called eyeless.
If you've identified a region
of sequence in a human,
in the human genome that's
mapping to an eye disease gene,
and you find out
that in that region,
there is a conserved
gene called eyeless,
might be a very
interesting gene for you.
So eyeless is a gene.
So here's a normal fly.
You see it has that
bright red eye.
The eyeless gene,
when mutated, results
in a fly that now just
doesn't have a white eye,
but has no eye altogether.
So it turns out that the
aniridia gene is the homolog
of the eyeless gene in flies.
That's not how it was
identified initially,
but nowadays, there's a lot of
information in model organisms.
And so if you're sort of
trying to identify a gene,
and you see that there's
a gene in the neighborhood
you're looking at
with a function that's
related to a gene
like eyeless, which
has a clear sort of analogy
in terms of phenotypes,
then that's going to increase
your interest in that gene.
So I'm going to come
back to this point
here, which is how
do we determine
whether a piece of DNA that's
on one of these inserts
that we're getting as we
walk across the chromosome,
how do we know whether
it is transcribed or not?
And to get at this, I'm
going to introduce you
to a concept which
is important in
and of itself, which
is the idea of cDNA.
So cDNA.
And specifically,
I'm going to show you
how one would make a cDNA
library, which is basically
a library of different cDNAs.
And so what cDNA is, as
shown up there on my slide,
a cDNA is complementary DNA.
It's complementary DNA,
meaning that is the complement
of an mRNA transcript.
This DNA is the complement
of an RNA or mRNA transcript.
One thing to watch out for is
it's not complimentary DNA.
So this is MIT.
This is a no compliment
zone, so I don't want
to see any complimentary DNA.
All right, so let's think
about complementary DNA.
So remember, we've talked
about the central dogma
and how DNA encodes for RNA,
which encodes for protein.
And so the information
flows from DNA
through RNA to protein.
But there are some
specialized cases in biology
where this information
flow is reversed.
So there can be a reverse
of information flow
where information
flows from RNA to DNA.
OK, so that's pretty cool.
Where does that happen?
Well, there are viruses,
such as retroviruses,
one example of a retrovirus
is HIV, and the virus life--
the virus genome is a
single-stranded RNA molecule,
and the life cycle of the virus
is that inserts into the host--
the host genome, which
is double-stranded DNA.
For a retrovirus to do that,
it needs to take its RNA genome
and make double-stranded DNA
in order for it to insert.
So this is an example in
biology, which is basically
breaking the rules that we
talked to you about earlier
in the semester.
Also, there are
retrotransposons which
do a similar process,
going from an RNA molecule
to double-stranded DNA.
So this is a specialized
case, and it's interesting,
and we can take advantage of it
to basically clone and identify
mRNA transcripts.
OK, so I'm going to tell you
how to make complementary DNA,
and I'll go through
a series of steps.
The first step is we want to
make complementary DNA of mRNA,
so we need a way
to purify the mRNA.
So anyone have any idea
how to purify mRNA?
First, we could maybe
draw an RNA molecule here.
What are some salient
features of mature mRNA?
Yeah, Carlos?
AUDIENCE: It'll have
the five-prime cap
[INAUDIBLE] phosphate.
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah, it'll
have a five-prime cap.
Anything else?
Jeremy?
AUDIENCE: Poly-A tail.
ADAM MARTIN: It'll
have a five-prime cap
and a poly-A tail.
I'm going to take advantage
mostly of the poly-A tail here.
So here, we have a poly-A tail.
OK, how might we use that
poly-A tail to purify mRNA?
Natalie?
AUDIENCE: Well, you
can add a [INAUDIBLE]
because you know
they're [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: Mm-hmm.
What sequence would you use?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: Yes.
So Natalie has suggested
using poly T, which
she said would stick to
this poly A tail because
of base pair hybridization, OK?
So let's say we have a bead
or some type of resin with dTs
hanging off of it.
So I'll draw a few
of them, but you'd
have maybe a lot of
them sticking off, OK?
So you have a bead with
pieces of DNA, all of which
are poly dT hanging off of it.
And then these poly dTs, if
you add cytoplasm from cells,
the mRNA in that cytoplasm is
going to stick to this poly dT
bead, and it will
stick with a higher
affinity than other things that
are non specifically sticking
to the beads, and you can
wash these beads with buffer
and salt to get rid
of everything that's
non-specifically
sticking to the bead,
and then you're left
with just a bead that's
enriched with mRNA, which
is what was specifically
sticking to this, OK?
So you could purify--
you're purifying the mRNA based
on its affinity for a poly dT,
OK?
So then you're going
to have enrichment
of mRNA in your sample.
And so then once
you have your RNA,
you're going to want to
somehow go from RNA to DNA, OK?
So the next step will involve
somehow going from RNA to DNA.
So let's draw our
piece of RNA here.
Here's our RNA.
It has a poly A
tail so it's mRNA.
There is 5 prime.
OK, so now we need to
take advantage of a trick.
We can still take
advantage of dT
because we can use
this as a primer
because polymerase
usually requires
some primer and a three prime
hydroxyl in order to extend.
Now, can we use DNA polymerase
to extend this primer?
Jeremy is shaking his head no.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because
DNA [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: Exactly.
So what Jeremy is
saying is DNA polymerase
is a DNA dependent
DNA polymerase, OK?
DNA polymerase can only use
this if this is DNA here, OK?
So we need a different type
of enzyme, essentially,
in order to make DNA
from RNA, and luckily,
molecular biologists--
actually one of whom
was here at MIT--
discovered this type
of enzyme, and it's
called reverse transcriptase.
Reverse transcriptase.
This is an enzyme that's
encoded by retroviruses in order
to make double
stranded DNA from RNA,
and that allows the retrovirus
to insert into the host genome,
OK?
And what reverse transcriptase
is is it's an RNA dependent DNA
polymerase, OK?
So it takes RNA
as its substrate,
and then it synthesizes DNA
on the opposite strand, OK?
So this is an RNA
dependent DNA polymerase.
OK, so if you add
reverse transcriptase
to mRNAs that have these dT
primers, then what you get
is a new strand,
which is DNA here.
This is the strand of DNA.
And then you have a strand
of RNA opposite it, OK?
So at this step, you
have a DNA RNA hybrid.
So this is a DNA RNA hybrid.
Let's see.
Reveal some more of this.
This is the process
which I'm basically
outlining on the board.
So then you want
double stranded DNA,
so you don't want this strand
of RNA that's down here,
so you have to get rid of it.
So you would degrade
the RNA, and this
is done using another
enzymatic activity, which
is derived from reverse
transcriptase, which
is termed RNAs H activity.
So you can add an
enzyme RNAs H, which
RNAs H takes this
DNA RNA hybrids
and degrades the
RNA part of it, OK?
So this is going to
degrade the RNA strand.
And if you degrade
the RNA strand,
then you're left with
a single strand of DNA.
So you have single
strand of DNA here,
and now what you need
to do is to synthesize
the second strand of DNA.
So you need a second
strand synthesis.
And so you need, again,
a primer in order
to prime the synthesis here.
So there are a variety
of ways to do this.
You can add some
type of hairpin,
which is five prime here
and three prime here,
and then you can use
either DNA, polymerase,
or reverse transcriptase, which
also can be a DNA dependent DNA
polymerase to transcribe
this strand here, OK?
So again, you add polymerase,
and now you've gone
and you've generated
double stranded DNA, OK?
So everyone see how we've
gone from an mRNA transcript,
and we've done the reverse of
everything we just told you
in the first half of the course
because we've gone from RNA
and we've made DNA, OK?
But this will be really
useful because now we
have a stable piece of DNA that
we can clone into a plasmid
and we have a record of
this transcript being
present in our sample, and we
can propagate that on and on,
so we've cloned it, OK?
All right, what's going to be
special about this piece of DNA
versus a piece of genomic DNA?
Natalie?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: Yes, so
Natalie suggesting
that it doesn't have introns,
and that's totally right.
So this is not like
genomic DNA, and what
Natalie said is because
mRNA is processed,
the introns are spliced out,
such the mature mRNA only
has the axons, and so this
piece of complementary cDNA
is going to have no introns.
How else is it different?
Yeah, Jeremy?
AUDIENCE: It's not
going to have promoters.
ADAM MARTIN: It's not
going to have a promoter.
Yes, Carmen?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
have [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: You might
see a poly A and T
sequence in the cDNA.
Yes, that's true.
OK, so you might have
poly A, poly T. I'm
going to focus on
the other part from--
there's going to be no promoter,
enhancer, regulatory sequences.
Basically, it's got no sequence
that's not transcribed, right?
The DNA is only going to have
the part of the gene that
was physically transcribed by
the RNA polymerase originally.
OK, so no
non-transcribed regions.
No non-transcribed regions,
and Carmen's absolutely right.
You will also have possibly
a poly A or poly T sequence.
OK, so when you get these
cDNAs, you might have--
you have more than
one mRNA in a sample
like a cytoplasmic extract,
so you're going to prime--
you're going to
make multiple cDNA
and different cDNAs will reflect
different transcripts that
are present in your sample, OK?
So you could have
one clone that's
one gene, another clone
that's a different gene,
and another clone
that's another gene,
and you could have thousands of
clones of these different DNAs.
What's going to be special
about what types of genes
are you going to get for
I guess different tissues.
Are they going to
be the same or not?
Yeah, Carlos?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: Exactly.
You're not going to see--
if you've prepared a tissue
and there is no gene being--
if one gene was not expressed
or transcribed in that tissue,
you will not get a cDNA
for that particular gene
in your library, OK?
So the representation of genes--
the representation of
genes in a cDNA library
is totally dependent on what
genes are being expressed, OK?
So this representation
is going to be
proportional to the expression
level, and the more genes--
the more a gene is
expressed in a given tissue,
the more copies of
cDNA for that gene
you would see in
the library, OK?
So there's really
a proportionality
between the number of
clones in a library
and the expression
level of a gene,
where in the most extreme
case, if this gene is not
expressed at all,
you're not going
to see it represented at
all in the cDNA library, OK?
And then a corollary
to this statement
is that if you make cDNA
libraries from different cell
types or different tissue
types, the cDNA libraries
are going to be different
between those different types
of sources of mRNA, OK?
So in other words,
different tissues
give you different cDNA.
OK, so there is the process.
So I went through
most of the side.
Yes, miles?
AUDIENCE: Is this a way you can
determine what gene sequences
are expressed in all cells?
Because in certain mRNA strands
across all tissue samples,
those are basic cell functions
and expressed in a [INAUDIBLE]
organism?
ADAM MARTIN: So you're
asking, if you grind up
like an entire
organism and if you
get a cDNA from that
library, could you
tell if it's expressed in
all different cell types?
Even if you have one cell
type that expresses a gene,
if you grind up the
entire organism,
then you're going to have some
mRNA that represents that gene.
So I don't think it would
be as an effective measure
to determine the ubiquity of
expression of a given gene,
but in just a minute,
I'm going to give you
a tool that would allow you
to answer the exact question
that you're asking, OK?
Any other questions
about the cDNA library?
OK.
So I just wanted to mention that
a comeback to this example I
gave on the identification
of the human CDK gene.
So remember, we started
with yeast that were mutant.
They had
temperature-sensitive mutants,
and we transformed these
mutants with a library,
but I didn't really tell
you what the library was.
It was in fact the cDNA
library from humans that
was transformed into yeast, OK?
And that's because yeast genes--
for the most part, they don't
have a lot of interests, and so
the yeast--
the machinery is not
able to splice out
the human interactions
and human genes, OK?
And so this was done
with a human cDNA
library, which then encoded--
one of which encoded the
cumin CDK gene, and that
allowed Paul Nurse to
discover the piece of DNA that
encoded for the human CDK, OK?
So I just wanted to
kind of retroactively
go back and sort of tell you
how that experiment was done.
OK, so now I'm going to
get to my final point
for this lecture, which is
this final technique, which
will allow us to determine
whether or not a transcript is
expressed in a single
cell type or ubiquitously
through an organism, and this
involves a technique, which
is known as hybridization.
And what hybridization
is is if you're
starting with a
piece of DNA, you
don't need to know
its sequence in order
to determine whether
there are sequences that
are similar or identical to
it, because hybridisation
is basically if you
have some sequence
and it's single stranded
such that you have a DNA
backbone but you
have base pairs that
are able to pair with
their complementary bases
and you can use a piece of
single stranded DNA like this
and you can label it such that
if the labeled piece sticks
to another piece that has
identical or similar sequence,
you'll be able to visualize
it in some way, OK?
So this is called--
you're looking for things
that anneal or hybridize
to a particular
specific sequence.
So you don't need to know
the sequence a priori, OK?
You just need to have this
physical piece of DNA,
and you can use this single
stranded piece of DNA
to then fish for
similar sequences, OK?
So we could take a piece of DNA
here maybe that's in a gene,
and we could fish
through a DNA library
to try to identify a cDNA clone
that has sequence identity
to that piece of DNA, OK?
And the way this is done
is to take a cDNA library.
So each of these colonies
here would express or have
a different clone of DNA.
You can then take a
nitrocellulose filter, put it
on this plate, which would
stick the bacteria in place
to that filter, and you
could then lice the bacteria
and denature the DNA, and then
the DNA is stuck to the figure,
but now it's single stranded.
You can then add your
probe, which is labeled,
and look for the colonies
that this probe sticks to,
and that would then identify
a particular cDNA, which
would identify whether
or not a piece of DNA
is expressed in a
given tissue type, OK?
So everyone see how
that would work?
So in addition to doing this
on a nitrous cellulose filter,
you can also do
this in a tissue,
and that's known as
in situ hybridization.
And in this case, in
situ hybridization,
you're searching for mRNA in
a section of fixed tissue.
OK, and I have an
example from this paper
here, which is the
paper this are cloned.
In this paper was the
cloning of the aniridia gene,
and they identified a gene of
interest, which is called Pax6
now, and they basically
used a piece of DNA
that they thought
was interesting,
and they did in situ
hybridization in an organism,
in this case, you see an eye.
This is an eye here,
and the label Pax6
is labeled in
yellow, and you can
see how this transcript
is present throughout
the entire eye, right?
And the way you would see if
it's tissue specific is you
look in other tissues and you
wouldn't see this yellow label.
So that's how you
would determine
if it's expressed in a
specific tissue or ubiquitously
throughout an organism.
OK, so this Pax6 gene.
Oop.
So I was going to
ask, what do you think
would happen if you
hyperactivate Pax6 in humans,
and this is one idea, but
actually, I just made that up,
or Stan Lee made that up,
but actually, Stan Lee never
in fact mentioned whether or
not cyclops is a Pax6 mutant,
but we can do a different type
of experiment, which might be
more ethical, which is we
know there's a fly gene that's
homologous to Pax6.
And what we can do in
flies is we can topically
express this islets
gene in non-eye tissues
and see what happens.
OK so, this is pretty wild.
This is my Halloween
image of the class.
So this is a fly
where eyeless has been
expressed all over its body.
OK, so here you see
there's an eye--
It's normal eye-- here.
You can see there's
now another eye
growing in the
front of its head.
You can see here's an eye
growing on this fly's back,
and you can see the legs.
There's eye tissue all over
the legs of this fly, OK?
So this Pax6 gene, which is
conserved from flies to humans
is the master regulator
of eye development, OK?
And at least in flies,
if you topically
express this in other parts
of the body, you get an eye.
I should say these are
not functionalized.
They don't hook up to
the brain the same way
the normal eye does.
So it's not like
this fly can see out
of the back of its head.
OK, that's it.
I'm done, and good luck
on your exam on Wednesday.
We will see you here.